Okay, thank you.
I know, it's exciting
'cause it's Christmas time.
I love Christmas in Los Angeles,
nothing beats the smell
of, uh, chestnuts roasting
-on an encampment fire.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Whoo! Yeah!
Ah, Christmas.
I love any holiday
-where you get to lie to kids.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
(CHUCKLES)
But actually, you know...
This week is actually
the sweet spot
in the holiday season, right?
Like, between Thanksgiving
and Christmas,
when there's no relatives
in the house.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I hate that,
when you sit on the toilet
and the seat
is the temperature of ass.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-So...
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
Here's a sweet holiday story.
Boston is having
a segregated Christmas party.
-(CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Did you read about this?
The City Council,
It's-- (CHUCKLES)
It's only 13 people.
-(CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Seven White,
six people of color,
but they had to, like,
uninvite the White people,
They said,
"This is a scandal now,"
'cause the mayor
sent out a thing, it said,
"Only the electeds of color,"
that's the phrase.
Electeds of--
Sounds like a Marvel movie.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-The Electeds of Color.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
I don't know why
we have to separate like this,
but okay, so, they don't like
the White folks at the party.
Some people
are saying it's racist,
some people are saying
it's possibly illegal,
but you have to admit,
it makes the DJ's job
a lot easier.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
And... (CHUCKLES)
...it's Christmas
at the White House.
Biden never knows
what to get Ukraine, you know?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
Last year, he fucked up,
and he just did cash, and...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
...Ukraine burst into tears,
and said,
"You make me feel like a whore."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Yeah! Yeah!
But you know, I tell you,
yeah, I don't know how you feel
about the Bidens,
but that is a family
that's made for Christmas.
Come on. I mean,
have you seen the pictures?
Joe wrapping the president--
presents,
Jill decorating the tree,
Hunter bringing the snow.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
Well, okay, so get this now.
The House, The Republican House,
of course... (BREATHES DEEPLY)
...they have voted
to have a formal inquiry now,
into impeaching Joe Biden,
they said it's a crucial step
in pretending to have
a reason to impeach him.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
But you know, look...
we all know
he has a troubled son.
Hunter, we've all seen
the pictures, the dick,
-the...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
You know,
the hookers, the cocaine.
I mean, you know,
it's not pretty.
Here's the Republicans' theory
why they're impeaching him,
that Biden-- (SMACKS LIPS)
President Biden
profited off his crackhead son.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Really, that's their thing.
(CHUCKLES)
As any parent of an addict
will tell you,
"That's when the cash
really starts rolling in."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
I thought it was a stretch
when they impeached Clinton
-over a blowjob, but...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...impeaching a guy
over your son's blowjob?
-That seems...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Yeah!
And of course...
a lot of these younger,
dumber Republicans,
-they don't--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
They don't know
the constitution,
they don't know anything
about impeachment.
Lauren Boebert asked,
"What did the president know,
and what's it like
to know things?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)